he's suave and sophisticated please
welcome pierce brosnan
good evening ladies and gentlemen please
forgive the voice or lack of voice but
I'm delighted to be here tonight to
acknowledge the work of a group of
artists the great sense of style please
join me in welcoming this year's
nominees for achievement in costume
design
and here to assist me from the
incredibles costume designer edna mold
you know Edna costume design is it's
alright darling you can turn off the
prompter I know what I want to say I am
on to present the evenings most
prestigious award well I wouldn't say no
specially just award film is a marvelous
medium for fashion display sometimes the
models emote too much but models where
actors skewer little performances
dialing drama emphasizes the movement of
the costumes well what was that nyla
Dixon and Richard Taylor show last year
the three-part show what they know Lord
of the Rings yes Nyla's customs came
alive for me I felt that this is what
wearing clothes in middle-earth must
have been the nominees are thank you
darling the nominees are
for the sumptuous costumes of the
aviator nominee sandy Pelle Juul her
inspiration from the larger-than-life
story of Howard shoes in the Golden Age
of Hollywood for Finding Neverland
nominee Alexandra Byrne recreated
fashions from turn-of-the-century
England when author JM Barrie wrote his
timeless children's classic Peter Pan
hmm more children I see this time in
Lemony Snicket's A Series of Unfortunate
Events the costumes of nominee Colleen
at work perfectly captured the innocence
of the Baudelaire family as they
maneuvered their way around the devious
Count Olaf and other narrative wells for
Ray the costumes of nominees Sharon
Davis followed the highs and lows of the
50-year career of legendary singer
songwriter and performer
Ray Charles for Troy nominee Bob
Ringwood had the daunting task of
providing costumes for the fierce armies
of ancient Greece the heroic men who led
them and the woman whose beauty could
launch a thousand ships
and the Oscar goes to Sandy Powell for
The Aviator
this is the second Academy Award and
sixth nomination for Sandy Powell
so many people to thank but most
importantly I'd like to thank my
colleagues and partners in crime
Debbie Scott and he hardly John cow Lisa
Padovani and David Davenport also a big
big THANK YOU to Marty for being the
inspiration for us all thank you
ah that's two for The Aviator so if if
Howard use were here right now he
wouldn't shake hands with anybody uh
when our next presenter is not dazzling
us with his acting ability he's boring
us to death with his politics please
welcome Academy Award winner Tim Robbins
come on